having someone
who's one of the top three rappers on
the planet
come from your city like
you know cole's an icon you know
uh he's a legend he's you know i always
say there's the uh the mount rushmore of
hip-hop and three of those slots
have been the same for like ten years
ago drake cole and kendrick
like how much of an inspiration was cole
growing up because like again like if
you're in the streets you might not be
listening to cole
you know i know because like you know
nicole's on some lyrical [ __ ] but like
man you can't help but probably be
inspired by that dude coming out of your
town right
no no cap the the first song that i
heard from j
cole was who that of course yeah and
and when when you were in fayetteville
he tried to video in favor that [ __ ]
went
crazy [ __ ] oh [ __ ] fever lit now like
no cat that
he's the martyr for the veal like [ __ ]
you're the only [ __ ] to come out excuse
me
but you aren't gonna come out bro we
look at him like yo i want to be that
so for him to to really put that
footprint on my city and
him to say my [ __ ] is amazing i'm behind
him bro that [ __ ] fire my big bro lit
and i'm little bro now so i'm
hey i'm cool with that you feel me yeah
i mean i mean there has to be a
there has to be the j cole morey song
bro i know he's tapped in if he hit no
look
we we talked and he a solid [ __ ] but if
he ever say more hop on this track i
promise you
i'm gonna fly away from that
[ __ ] and i'm hopping on the song
in person
the next dreamville for you know they
did that with the last dreamville
project
they just flew everybody in like right
that was the most random
like like assortment of artists on one
pro like yeah you got that's got to be
that's
that's got to be that's going to happen
i hope so debut album you got to get the
call first
on your album my mixtape is out so no no
your mixtape's out but i'm saying
album we're calling it a mixtape so that
means the album's coming yeah hell yeah
j cole you see me hey follow my boy oh
god
i'll [ __ ] with it oh god i'll fold it up
too hard the baby too
ain't nothing to stand the [ __ ] up